At the time the full extent
of his crimes became clear,
in October 2012,
Jimmy Savile
was still revered
as a British institution.
His name was emblazoned
throughout hospitals
across the UK.
Streets were
named after him.
But during the weeks
that followed,
over a year
after his death in 2011,
Savile was revealed
as one of Britain's most
prolific sexual abusers.
That is a complete
flight of fantasy.
For those
that don't know him,
it's hard to articulate
exactly how famous
Savile was in the UK.
His bleached hair,
gold jewellery,
and outlandish clothes
were cultivated
to make him stick
in the collective memory
of the British people.
When he rose to fame
in the 1980s,
most UK presenters
spoke stiffly,
in perfect English.
And as an unrefined miner
from a working-class area,
Savile felt like a fresh,
genuine voice.
Good morning, my sweetheart.
-How's things?
-Oh, alright.
Give us a kiss, baby.
He became as established
as the likes
of Oprah Winfrey
or David Letterman -
the sort of household name
whose fame
spanned generations.
A kind of private
pandemonium.
Many parents grew up
listening to him on Radio 1,
and their children watched
him on Jim Will Fix It,
a hugely popular show,
which ran from 1975 to 1994,
often receiving
20,000 letters a week
from its enraptured
audience.
Savile also presented
Top of the Pops…
Good evening,
ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to Top of the Pops.
…a music show, which,
at its peak in the 70s,
was watched
by 15 million people a week,
around a quarter
of the British population
at the time.
But Savile's
novelty figure persona
hid horrific secrets.
Over his 53-year career,
Savile abused
countless victims,
aged five to 75.
After his death,
over 450 people came forward
with allegations.
Being able
to lock things away…
was the way I coped.
His predatory behaviour
was allowed to flourish
for over five decades,
and Savile's power
and calculating influence
meant that many accusations
about his behaviour
were dismissed
as ridiculous.
That sort of thing did
happen in the pop business.
Savile was able to escape
justice for so long
because of his proximity
to influential people.
It's difficult to reconcile
with his clownish persona,
but he wielded
genuine power.
He became synonymous
with large demonstrative
charity projects,
raising over
40 million pounds
through events
that often gained
widespread media coverage.
He was awarded
an OBE in 1972
and a knighthood in 1990,
one of the highest honours
the Crown can bestow.
No, it really is mine.
-Are you sure?
-It's mine, I'm telling you.
It's mine, yeah.
Tell him it's mine.
It is mine.
Thought I'd nicked it.
He was an unofficial adviser
to members
of the royal family,
the governor of Broadmoor,
a high-security
psychiatric hospital,
and an esteemed member
of the Catholic Church.
He regularly dined
with Margaret Thatcher
while she was
prime minister,
and met the pope on his
visit to the United Kingdom.
He was friends
with some of the most famous
musicians in the world.
Governments, the monarchy,
and established
British institutions,
such as the BBC and NHS,
all trusted Savile.
This place would
not be in existence
without Jimmy Savile.
But his benevolent
persona was a lie,
created to overshadow
the truth
about who and what he was.
Some celebrities and
producers did raise concerns
about Savile's behaviour,
but nothing ever came of it.
And if they were ignored,
there was even less chance
of hearing the voices
of the vulnerable,
disenfranchised people
upon whom Savile prayed.
The revelations about Savile
led directly
to Operation Yewtree,
a police investigation into
sexual abuse allegations,
which led to the conviction
of other British
celebrities,
such as Rolf Harris,
Gary Glitter,
and Dave Lee Travis.
You can watch the full story
in Jimmy Savile:
A British Horror Story
available on Netflix now.
I am often tempted.
In fact, my case
comes up next Thursday.